as I want to talk about this historical
games I guess period piece would be the
film term but I don't know Rob like
there's a little there's a bunch of
games that have gone into like this kind
of using an actual setting to set a tone
or tell a story do you have any like
favorites that come to mind I remember
showing like having just got like a ps2
and showing my I believe i believe it
was Medal of Honor frontline and you
know of course like a lot of those call
of duty games came out like after saving
private ryan and we were you know that
movie really changed like how people
visualized and not so much rent room
anta sizes that war and man that like
frontline seen in the beginning where
you're like on the landing craft just
like private ryan like planes was by I
remember like seeing that and then
showing like Mike my mom and she was
like this is incredible yeah we were
blown away like I remember like that for
me was like the height of video games at
that time yeah cuz that was it was weird
because that was one of the first games
I can remember where you get onto the
beach and your objective wasn't to shoot
somebody it was just to shoot like
suppressing fire I don't know if you
remember right and you you're the rest
of the American troops wouldn't move up
the beach until you just fire your
Thompson up there a little bit and yeah
now that seems known like in battlefield
one you get suppression bonuses for just
shooting in an enemy's direction if
they're gonna cover but yeah I remember
that was just straight out of Saving
Private Ryan like that intro scene that
um thanks it Spielberg never buddy
worked on was just unreal and it did
definitely set tone because later on it
gets more to the Espionage stuff right
you're kind of like a covert soldier
later on you go on to like German
u-boats to sabotage their supplies and
whatnot but yeah I don't know but like I
wonder how much research went into that
game as far as like making it
historically accurate holy I had a
similar experience with allied assault
which also depicted the storming the
beach at Normandy and just yeah like so
much stuff happening around you which at
the time was pretty new like shooter
campaigns were very like hey you're in a
room there's some guys that you run and
shoot and keep going and whatever this
was very much like no no no you're
participating you're just one small cog
in this much larger battle and there's
stuff blowing up around you people dying
around you just seeing that and being
immersed in that was very new and very
like spectacular for the time and yeah i
mean it is cool just to be sort of very
i hate the word but viscerally
experiencing a piece of history like
that to know that like this is a
recreation of something it actually
happened and we're talking about
historical periods and period pieces and
games and clearly World War two is one
of the most like you know deeply mind
sources of history for you know material
and I think they mean as you mentioned
we've covered a lot of different aspects
of that war and in a lot of different in
interesting ways yeah and I remember I
think call of duty to came along that
was my first xbox 360 game and that
instead of storming so it's omaha beach
in a in metal honor frontline elytis all
I believe it's Omaha Beach too but then
like Utah Beach was the one that we
stormed to link up with the 10 1st
Infantry after they dropped behind enemy
lines at night before Pointe du Hoc and
called 32 when the Rangers were scaling
those cliffs so yeah I read up pretty
extensive account of it like afraid of
what book it was I think it was citizen
soldiers stephen ambrose who wrote band
of brothers also wrote citizen soldiers
and they were scaling these cliff to
take out these like anti naval guns i
think and then they got there the
Germans already moved on so Intel was
bad but like that was all so unreal
because again that was my first 360
games so that like each time I play like
a newer game obviously front line isn't
gonna look good right now but then you
get like it doesn't call duty to which
doesn't even look that great now but at
the time was like this is unreal yeah
and you know it's weird because like now
we have battlefield one come around and
that was a big thing like I have how
much the campaign if you played I
actually played a good amount I've been
kind of holding back for the pc and i
finally got up got into that played like
that kind of like that um I suppose it's
just like the intro of the game
prolonged the prologue yeah that was
super uncomfortable I just like a little
scream like we when we did the stream
the other day and playing the operations
mode on for you've seen it at all Scott
but like there's a lot more narrative
but I would say there's a lot more like
emotion like there are people blowing
that whistle and then just tons of
people just screaming and charging there
is something extremely unsettling about
like playing that game one it looks
freakin unreal and just shooting people
feels extremely uncomfortable compared
to like i don't know i made it you want
to compare it to like frontline like we
said but there's something about how it
looks the mud knowing about world war
one
heard World War two like yeah it's was
not nearly as like in a lot of ways
black is white riya and that was the
thing about I remember like now that
you're talking about there's that scene
from like enemy at the gates that we
were talking about it was in Call of
Duty finest hour when you're running
across some red square in Stalingrad and
then you got one guy with a rifle one
guy with a bandolier in case he does
like you pick it up and shoot and that's
kind of the same thing we're a
battlefield one from what I play to the
campaign but little I played and from
multiplayer the operations motors
talking about it's a story-driven like
kind of I guess pertinent to this
conversation it's that story driven what
would have happened if the Germans
defended this in the Italian Alps and
you know like the you know the u.s.
actually pushed them back or what if the
u.s. actually failed and there is much
more impact of battlefield one and you
know frostbite engine helps like having
that like the condensation on the guns
the mud on your gun when you go prone
and get back up it creates a better
sense of place again these are like maps
designed to be fun in the end and they
are kind of they're trying to shed light
on these like lesser known historical
accounts did campaign do that much
farther in like I no one is Lawrence of
Arabia one is uh there's like a was an
Italian he's like a heavy trooper right
and he's telling his granddaughter's
telling the story from his point of view
yeah I've gone the phone okay yeah
anyway like that game itself kind of I
like that they actually I know Miguel
concepts you know we're gonna have him
come on and talk more about his review
in a few minutes but he was saying
there's a lot it's bleak the campaign
yeah he said it almost feels ham-fisted
but then when you look at it maybe it
should because world war one is the war
that like call the great works we didn't
know anything like that would ever
happen again but I don't know to get
away from the more depressing side of
games LA noire is one of my mm-hmm I
that game is so flawed in so many ways
and especially the core mechanics I know
if you did you guys play LA noire oh
yeah it did not need to be an open-world
game no not at all good because the
conversation cool thing and then put the
setting like that just LA and the
fifties reminds me of like um I don't
know just like a ton of movies are set
there um la Confidential's when I get
movies and it nails that like the way
they debate dresses the facial animation
capture helped but I remember that just
every time I talk to somebody their
accents a lot of people from Mad Men
where the show the main character in
Eleanor's Ken Cosgrove from mad men do
um I don't know what did you think of
you said he didn't need to be open world
why do you think that you should like
more linear would you preferred well
because it was basically an adventure
game that for whatever reason was set in
an open world didn't really make sense
mean the game was all about you know
acting adds a detective in classic Los
Angeles right in vintage LA there was no
reason to like include driving and
shooting in that really I mean there was
all this attention paid to like you know
the voice acting and facial capture as
you mentioned at the time was pretty
revolutionary even if it looks a little
bit wonky in bizarre now so it's weird
to me that they would invest all those
resources in that aspect of the game and
this really unique an interesting aspect
of the game and then shoehorn that into
this open-world structure I mean from
what I remember that game had a pretty
tortured development cycle and or
whatever people suspect that Rockstar
was kind of like pressuring team bondi
to finish the project and they were not
happy with how things were turning out
and that may have directed certain
design decisions and that might be why
the game turned out the way it did but
yeah I mean the sections for me of that
game their most memorable or always like
the interrogations or the investigation
investigation of the game I don't
remember any of the driving or shooting
like that was all completely unnecessary
like the core experience in my mind but
her pretty right on yeah the city was
really cool and it's really interesting
to go to LA and see what remains of that
time period because there are still
traces of that in in Los Angeles there's
not much of it but if you go to like
Broadway if you go to old like East LA
that were like what used to be downtown
you can still see like Art Deco
buildings and like traces of this
architecture that's still around even if
much of the city has kind of moved on
and forgotten that portion of its past
mhm yeah it's always interesting to see
these like vestigial things like that
have remained since the past like I
don't know like New York City has a ton
of that still like San Francisco you
know like different a weird like
smorgasbord of different kind of
architectural styles and everything but
it's that kind of leads Madame X 1 the
Assassin's Creed series you know like
they were yearly for a while or by like
biannual depending on who was developing
them they're all new Ubisoft but like
you know which studio Ubisoft but you
know that was always the allure of what
was the next Assassin's Creed game where
I was going to be set the first one was
pretty cool because like I think I mean
we didn't know what the series was when
the first one was announced but then the
next one comes along it's Renaissance
Italy and people were asked
for like Japan like feudal Japan for the
entire series and I wouldn't be
surprised I still came back and did that
but these games are always cool like the
amount of research that Ubisoft it put
into like checking these cities out
obviously again they took creative
liberties when making them fun and like
making it fun for like SEO and Altair to
scale but I don't know my my favorite
Assassin's Creed was always assassin's
creed brotherhood which took the Italian
setting and then just like focused on
Rome but of course like because of game
play things it was my favorite with the
actual overarching training your
Assassin's but in terms of just like the
setting like that was awesome like you
get to really like stylize you go
Leonardo da Vinci for like inventions
and whatnot that helped me fight people
but I don't know did you have you like
had a lot of experienced assassin creed
games the second one was where I got
pulled in we're like that going to where
it's at yeah I mean it was where it was
where I was enjoying the open world of
it like in the rooftops and all and all
that stuff yeah definitely that's that's
my favorite one I think you know the
third one was was cool like man was the
the level of excitement I had 43 was so
high like home and he's got a hatchet
like you know like patriot like just the
movie just you have all these ideas of
what that game could have been but I
that game was just loaded with bugs and
that was where I where I lost it was
also every mission give er give you the
exact same speech of like wars difficult
people don't understand that was
literally everyone's like okay we get
into his wouldn t shades of grey fine
yeah whatever yeah that trailer there
yeah uh it was all I mean like that I'm
I'm a sucker for like that setting just
like you said um like Revolutionary War
era and then like Connor I forget how
you pronounce it like actual given name
rag rag Akua Gregor Kyle conor mcgregor
but yeah a UFC fighter in Assassin's
Creed 3 was a weird reference Scott
Quebec it's the only Connor you know
it's kind of a great those personally
came to mind man a head makes it so
quick good work I love it um yes and
then like he comes along and he seems
cool but then like I didn't like how he
was written I thought he was kind of a
baby in a lot of ways but I was kind of
rooting and yeah and understandably so
but it's also just like if you're with
that character for 20 hours eventually
it was like alright dude you
really really shut the hell up yeah and
then they just like started like forcing
that on that colonies board game stuff
into it um the homestead stuff which i
don't think is great that's one like the
Naval Staff Ganges and that's what's so
funny was the naval stomach it was like
what and just to have black flag wasn't
after that yeah it was it was my like
now that I think about I assassin's
creed two brothers my favorite
Assassin's Creed game but like black
black flag I still have the urge to go
back and pledge because not for the
parts that were fell like a statin
screen just for the sailing and being a
pirate and you unlock you find those
pages so your crew can sing those
different songs there's a weird name for
them and then they're just singing like
yo ho yo oh and then just flying over
the waves like smoking these gigantic
ships that's gorgeous it was one of my
first ps4 games after call duty ghosts
and that series like I mean it's so
weird to have this year that we don't
have an assassin's creed syndicate last
year in a Industrial Revolution kind of
turn of the century London I didn't play
much unfortunately um maybe I will at
some point yeah that series has covered
a lot of ground though I mean even
especially if you're including like
graphic novels and other stuff like in
that same University I think there was
I'm fairly confident there was a comic
book set in feudal Japan basing these
assets greed universe ok and then may
have also been like one of the
side-scrolling games I'm trying to
member what that sort of sub series was
called well there's three of them right
yeah there's there's 31 set in Russia
one I believe was China hand or maybe it
was China chronicles China Chronicle
yeah I didn't play any any The
Chronicles game so I only have a dim
recollection of this unfortunately but
regardless yes I mean if we're talking
about historical games assassins creed
is like covered more ground than just
about any other franchise yeah seem like
a printing conversation we have
battlefield one it was a big deal
because they're not going futuristic
like titanfall and infinite warfare and
like black ops treated last year it's
just one of those military shooters that
kind of broke the mold by going back to
something that has already been done to
death or not World War one but that kind
of you know like 20th century War era
don't forget sibs out at the end of the
week which encompasses all of history
exactly really civitate a fair amount of
save with my preview build and I know
you're reviewing right now we can't talk
about the review build too much when I
play the preview yeah it's just like you
get like really cool stories out of like
twist on history like I know the one
thing that I'm
4 x's and 2k actually don't like to talk
about it but apparently Gandhi's estate
like doesn't like when people bring up
civilization this video game series like
Gandhi his like his like a state does
not like it because there's that one
glitch where his personality would go so
far in the negative like on the good
side that it would circle back to the
max aggressive and he would just nuke
everyone's help so you know they don't
think it's super funny not sure we're
supposed to be talking about it now but
they don't like when you like when
civilization is brought up in relation
to Gandhi because of that glitch but
yeah he's like oh great this was never
nine times to happen but yeah like it
was just some weird program thing were
you become so peaceful yeah that it
would loop around and he has become like
the ultimate G would just attack
everyone in sounds like a robot you look
up youtube videos that people with like
Kim batting Gandhian civ5 it's hilarious
yeah it's like I said like civilization
that's one of my favorite that's one of
the reasons like some of it's my
favorite series you get that like weird
twists on history based on like these
real people in real places but yeah
those dudes in other history guys are
like big history buffs yeah this weird
twists where Gandhi had a bunch of new
yeah but anyway so that is our
discussion on historical video games
period pieces what do you think let us
know in the comments below what games
you have played that set a good tone
kind of paint a location in favorable
ways